you can't control
i mean look at the shift it's funny
because
merchant i've been doing a show even
before with this we were doing shows for
many years and you know we were covering
um
remember the occupy wall street movement
right oh man i remember that where it
was like oh man corporations are bad man
corporal
and now these same people like it's
amazing to me and i've said this how
quickly
how quickly leftists turn into ron paul
libertarians when it comes to censoring
now they love corporations private
company bro
brother private company i'm like wait a
second as long as they throw a few
sardines yeah they're like not even
it's not it's not gonna seal it's a big
fish the fish is so little gives it
here you go and they're like oh i love
the big corporation the monopoly now
yeah no they love it i mean like you
were bringing up we talked about it on
one of our shows you know
all the pr all the pride flags on all
these things and it's funny because like
bethesda one of the gaming companies
like you know they have bethesda us but
that's
australia all of them had changed their
logo to a pride flag
except for bethesda middle east oh
volkswagen too
volkswagen all the every region
except middle east there was volkswagen
dubai and it was just a regular logo
i mean look at disney disney's one of
the most woke people in the world but
when china tells them we don't want any
black people on our posters they take
them off oh yeah
that's right they have they photoshopped
the black guy off the star wars posters
oh yeah
for the from the new star wars listen i
love asian people okay
my sister's korean adopter they're great
people but the chinese government and
the leaders are like the most racist
like
gigi ping gives speeches where he
admires him and stalin and our media
just ignores it
i mean he they all they want power their
leadership this
that's why they own biden the chinese
dictator won't even meet with biden
they won't even meet with the press
secretary any they won't be the
secretary of state
because to them it's almost shameful
that they own us
they're not like okay we already own
them don't show we own them
so that's why they won't even meet with
our leaders because they're so
embarrassed
it's the uh it's because once they
dominate you then it's embarrassing to
even meet on a stage
with their dog well you're right and you
know and the other thing is and you find
is that
china has always respected power right
they've respected
they've respected when they did
interviews of people in china about
they're like oh you know i like trump
actually because trump you know he shows
power he's
i'm talking about the citizens of china
oh yeah he shows power he's
he's a strong man
biden is completely weak right that's a
very east
asia asian thing it's a well-known deal
they don't want to be associated with
weakness
the japanese the chinese think if you're
associated with weakness you'll be
coming that's why they won't even touch
biden
they they won't even touch kamala the
latin americans won't they're like
we want to be met with a real leader
you're insulting us
sending this puppet they're all telling
the world this is a puppet this is a
muppet
we don't meet with muppets yeah same
thing with north korea that's why
kim jong-un started meeting with us
because he was like all right i kind of
like this trump guy he's like he's kind
of a gangster all right
he won't even talk to biden exactly he
was at least he was at least
impressed by trump like he was at least
like at least i get to meet donald trump
that's kind of cool
like that at least puts you in a good
position to go in and negotiate whereas
yeah like people saw because trump
before
they completely smeared his name and by
the way
trump made a lot of mistakes in his
presidency i'm
very pissed at him still so i'm not
defending everything i'm not pretending
like he's some [ __ ]
flawless god but what they did to him
and his family and his associates i mean
they
ruined these people's lives and smeared
them as racist
clan members let me give you this in
closing because i can talk all night my
wife's gonna get mad if i don't think
yeah it's okay let me raise you want to
fix the cable that's right it's from
let me guess it actually fixes the cable
but seriously that's exactly
it trump made a lot of mistakes either a
lot of things were wrong but it doesn't
matter he was the man of the arena and
and the globalist totally targeted him
so he's the idea
of a free real president that they fear
and hey
doesn't mean that as the man he was
perfect but the idea of he was a real
president he actually tried to call the
shots that's why they hated trump
so that's why i support trump but still
support him but this
here's why i like trump more than ever
because i was get really pissed him
about going along with the vaccine which
he's ignorant about
trump um they've told him it's in the
news but i know from sources very close
to trump and you know talking to him
they've told trump if you keep calling
for an audit of the
election if you keep trying to leave the
republican party which is the republican
president out of power
until another's elected he's our leader
of the republicans that's just that's
just the way it works
if you do that we're going to indict
your son giuliani and you
and he didn't back down he's having
rallies so they're getting ready to try
to indict his family
so the fact is he's not backing down and
so it's like they say in full metal
jacket
well joker's silly and he's ignorant but
he's got guts and guts is enough
it only makes me admire trump that he is
standing up at this point
despite these threats of arrest by these
george soros lackeys